♪
>> Please clear the aisles and
take your seats so we can start.
♪
[ Playing Pomp and Circumstance
]
♪
[ Applause ]
colleagues, families, friends
DEAN COOLEY:  Faculty,
and students: I am delighted to
welcome you to the 321st
Commencement of Yale University
and to the 161st anniversary of
the year in which Yale conferred
its first, and the nation's
first, Ph.D. degree.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
Today we celebrate your
accomplishments as scholars and
researchers, and we award the
degrees earned by your
dedication to the advancement of
human knowledge.
We are extremely proud of what
you have achieved in your time
at Yale, and we thank you for
your contributions to your
field. Congratulations to you
all!
[ Applause ]
To begin today's ceremony, I
first wish to recognize those
graduate students and faculty
who received prizes at
yesterday's convocation
ceremony. Your program lists the
student academic prizes.
At this time, I ask all student
prize winners and their advisers
who are present to stand so that
we can thank the advisors for
their guidance and congratulate
the students on their
achievements.
Prize winners, please stand.
[ Applause ]
Each year, the Graduate Mentor
Awards celebrate faculty members
who have been outstanding
graduate students. rs
The four faculty members who
received the award this year
exemplify the many important
qualities to which all graduate
teachers should aspire.
At this time, I ask our mentor
prize-winners in attendance
today to stand so that we can
recognize their excellence.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
These four faculty represent all
the professors and instructors
who ve hped all of you
navigate graduate school.
You have also been supported by
many others on campus whose
labor and loyalty contribute to
make Yale the distinguished
University it is.
Let me name just a few of Yale's
employees beyond faculty who
stand at the heart of Yale. And
when each finished, we can thank
them all.
The University's custodial and
maintenance staff make Yale look
beautiful and keep us in good
condition all year long.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
The Hospitality stf fe us
Commencement and throughout the
year.
The clerical and technical staff
conduct the University's
business with acumen and
dispatch.
The managerial and professional
staff direct and administer our
departments and schools.
And, specifically, the staff of
the Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences sustains the
institution within which Yale
graduate education thrives.
For all of these wonderful
women and men of Yale, I ask for
recognition through applause
from students, friends, and
family alike.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
Finally, and separately, I also
ask you to acknowledge the
superb musical abilities of our
organist, Mr. Philip Balkan -
one of our many accomplished
students at Yale College who is
playing on one of the world's
great pipe organs here in
Woolsey Hall.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
Now just a few words to our
graduating students. Candidates
for the Ph.D., M.Phil, and
master's degrees, before we
begin the honor of conferring
your diplomas.
I know for many of you, getting
to this graduation day has not
been easy, especially the last
couple of years, but you have
prevailed.
You have taken advantage of all
Yale Graduate School offers as
you pursued your studiesnd
scholarly research. During your
time with us, you have learned
that the way of research and
scholarship is neither straight
nor smooth.
A line of inquiry may take you
nowhere, and months of work may
bear no fruit. An experiment may
go awry, and you find yourself
back at square one.
Graduate study takes
inspiration, but also hard work,
and especially perseverance and
determination.
Learning to continue in the face
of challenges characterizes the
ability to do advanced research,
and the fact that you sit here
today means you have learned
that lesson. You have overcome
all of the obstacles that stood
in your way and completed your
studies in triumph.
Today, you leave Yale as
thinkers, explorers, creators,
teachers - and you also leave
with a set of skills that equip
you for a variety of careers.
You are innovative and critical
thinkers, problem solvers,
leaders, team players and
effective communicators poised
to launch fulfilling careers.
Whatever direction you choose to
apply your skills of advanced
learning, let your
accomplishments inspire you to
tackle new challenges with the
confidence that you have the
skill to navigate all
difficulties.
As a Yale graduate student, you
are given the opportunity to
contribute to society -- sorry,
I should have said as a Yale
graduate, you can contribute to
society, and to make a
difference in your field of
study. As you go forth, I
hope that you will also stay
engaged and in touch with us as
alumni and consider mentoring
those who follow in your
footsteps.
It has been my privilege to lead
the Graduate School's efforts to
provide you with the environment
in which you grew into the
scholars you are today. I am
proud of all that you have
accomplished and excited to see
what you will do next.
Congratulations!
[ Applause ]
And now we will award the
graduate degrees.
We will call the graduates to
the stage by the department or
program in which they have
earned their degrees. For those
students receiving more than one
degree, all diplomas will be
awarded together.
Dean Jasmina Besirevic will read
the citations.
Please come forward as your name
is called.
To congratulate the degree
recipients, you may be joined at
the front of the stage by
faculty members from eac
departm.
And please, everyone, applaud as
often as possible.
[ Laughter ]
Dean Besirevic.
DEAN BESIREVIC:  For the degrees
in African American Studies,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Bian Dan
For the degrees in African
Studies, maMaster of Arts:
Charlotte Marie Bednarski
Edward Jerome Hendrickson
Thomas Albert Mbajjwe
Enoch Osei Koduah
For the degrees in American
Studies, Doctor of Philosophy:
Kristin Ann Hankins
Jub Ubuntu Sankofa
For the degrees in Anthropology,
Doctor of Philosophy:
George Wu Bayuga
Elizabeth Berk
Tri Mac Phuong
For the degrees in Applied
Physics, Doctor of Philosophy:
Mary Lou Padlan Bailey
Hanwen Zhang
Xiaoyu Zhang
Master's of Science:
Weiru Chen
Andrew James Nielsen
For the degrees in Ecological
Studies, Master's of Arts:
MinJoo Choi
Erin Elora Hazel Kuhn
Jay Lynn Leggett
Elizabeth Wuellner
For the degrees in Architecture,
Doctor of Philosophy:
David Turturo
For the degrees in Astronomy,
Doctor of Philosophy:
For the degree in Cell Biology,
Jacob Andrew Culver
EkerinMikhlovna Stroeva
Sisi Yang
For the degrees in Cellular and
Molecular Physiology, Doctor of
Philosophy: Matthew Ellis.
Jinyu Li
For the degre i Chemistry,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Omar Mustapha Beleh
Danielle Confair
Matthew Rtan Espinosa
Olivia Francis Goethe
Robert Donald Hale
Hao-Li Huang
Maria Elena Liosi
Sayoni Mitra
Deepto Mozumdar
han Alexander Perets
Evan Perets
Krystle Marie Reiss
Shanelle Rashida Shillingford
Jacob Alan Spies
Elizabeth Ann Stone
Zhen Tao
Martin Tomanik
Master's of Science:
Isaiah Aguilar
Natalie Williams
For the degrees in Comparative
Literature, Doctor of
Philosophy:
Victoria Ann Baena
Vanessa Gubbins
Xavier Lee
For the degrees in Computational
Biology and Bioinformatics:
Guannan Gong
Hussein Mohsen
Zhaolong Yu
Geyu Zhou
For the degrees in Computer
Science, Doctor of Philosophy:
William Hallahan
Christopher Robert Harshaw
Bo Hu
Zihui Li
Master of Science:
Chris Cai
Qingxuan Cao
Yuhao Ding
Yaru Gong
Sunjun Gu
Theodore Jeffrey Hague
Xinli Hou
Die Hu
Chaogang Huang
Yu Ji
Haipeng Li
Zhouyang Li
Zhiyu Liang
Jiangshan Lin
Zhaowei Lin
Jianzhi Liu
Yifan Liu
Arjun Vijay Nair
Muhammed Yavuz Nuzumlali
Weiqi Peng
Yuelan Sheng
Ziyu Song
Haihao Sun
Xiangru Tang
Zihan Tang
Bingyao Wang
Ruopeng Wang
Wenbei Wang
Zhichen Wang
Yan Wen
Yuanpei Wu
Zhewei Wu
Han Xiao
Bingyi Yang
Jinshu Yang
Tongyu Yang
Derek Jaming Yeh
Keen You
Bo Zhao
Yankun Zhao
Yizhi Zhao
Diyuan Zhu
Jinhan Zhu
Yuxin Zhu
For the degrees in Earth and
Planetary Sciences, Doctor of
Philosophy:
Daniel Edmund Gaskell
Zheng Gong
Joachim Katchinoff
Yantao Luo
Master of
Master of Philosophy:
For the degrees of East Asian
Language, Doctor of Philosophy:
Yun Bai
Cheng Li
For the degrees in East Asian
Studies, Master's of Arts:
Ethan Glenn Barkalow
Jonathan Bertram
Chiu Yee Chasn
Siming Chen
Jiarong Fa
Tyler James Hayward
Suiyun Pan
Brenda Wei En Tan
Sabrina Jean Williams
Xuechen Yang
Chloe Young
For the degrees in Ecology and
Evolutionary Biology, Doctor of
Philosophy:
Alejandro Damian Serrano
Master of Science: Diego Soto
For t degree in Economics,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Julian Aramburu
Nathan Earl Barker
Paula Andrea Calvo
Robert John Finlay
Jonathan Thomas Hawkins
Koohyun Kwon
Weicheng Min
Ahyan Panjwani
Luca Perdoni
Sourav Sinha
Jaehee Song
Xiaochuan Xing
Kohei Yata
For the degrees in Engineering
and Applied Science, in the
program of Biomedical
Engineering, Doctor of
Philosophy:
Andrew Eric Sharp Barentine
Margaret Elise Bullock
Ann Tai Chen
Zachary Ryan Connerty-Marin
Jenette Gaylen Creso
Minsoo Khang
Chang Liu
Ons M'Saad
Samantha Rossano
Hao Xing
Master of Science:
Yinan Cheng
Aaron Spencer Mathias
Aurelie Moutran
Siqi Wei
In the program of Chemical and
Environmental Engineering,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Alisha Yee Chan
Uri Roei Gabinet
Molly Kathleen Grun
Omar Qaboos Imran
Rodrigo Bento Reboucas
Xuechen Zhou
In the program of Electrical
Engineering, Doctor of
Philosophy:
Shuwen Deng
Rui Li
Zhan Liu
Joshua Brian Surya
Yihang Yang
In the program of Mechanical
Engineering, Material Science,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Walter Gottlieb Bircher
Naijia Liu
Pengzi Liu
Khoi Dac Nguyen
Joshua Voges Pondick
Dylan Shah
Neelima Sharma
John Durkin Treado
Ali Yawar
For the degrees in English
Language and Literature, Doctor
of Philosophy:
Samuel James Huber
Shayne McGregor
Brandon Adam Menke
Sarah Anne Robbins
For the degrees in Environment,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Adam Zachary Andis Arietta
Kyra Alexandra Prats
Mario Alipio Soriano
For the degrees in European and
Western Studies, Master's of
Arts:
Giorgi Buzaladze
Ningyuan Chen
Zachary Klaus Cho
Meagan Elizabeth Ford
Gabriel Malvin Simon Rom
Ali Salmenbayev
For the degrees in Experimental
Pathology, Doctor of Philosophy:
Christopher William Anderson
Jocelyn Fang-Yi Chen
Samuel Robert Kerr
Meaghan Kathleen McGeary
For the degrees in Film and
Media Studies, Doctor of
Philosophy:
For the degrees in French,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Chandler Marie Abshire
Doyle David Calhoun
Richard Riddick
For the degrees in Genetics,
Doctor of
Doctor of Philosophy:
Syndi Marissa Barish Philosophy:
Syndi Marissa Barish
Vaughn Colleluori
Kimberly Nicole Griffin
Alison Driscoll Kochersberger
Alexandra Elizabeth MacColl
Garfinkel
Steven Paniagua
Paul Alexander Renauer
Yinyu Wu
For the degrees in Germanic
Languages and Literature, Doctor
of Philosophy:
Cecilia Sebastian
For the degrees in History,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Ricardo Jose Alvarez-Pimentel
Excuse me.
Liana Christine DeMarco
Anna Duensing
Kelly Goodman
Hannah Greenwald
Amanda Joyce Hall
Charlotte Kiechel
Kayhan Aryan Nejad
Ellen Mary Nye
Bennett Haley Parten
Samuel John Severson
Naomi Sussman
Beans Velocci
Master's of Arts:
Wiktor Babinski
Leo Joachim Henry app
Olivia Martha Mozdzierz
Gillian Merritt Reinhard
Wulfstan Scouller
Ella Starkman-Hynes
Olivia Marion Young
For the degrees in History of
Art, Doctor of Philosophy:
Tara Devendra Contractor
Philippe L.B. Halbert
Mohit Manohar
Shweta Raghu
Selin Unluonen
Andrew Peter Vielkind
For the degrees in
Immunobiology, Doctor of
Philosophy:
Yiyun Cao
Tyler Rice
Camila Robles-Oteiza
Hao Xu
Yexin Yang
For the degrees in
Interdepartmental Neuroscience
Program:
Gabriela Maria Bosque-Ortiz
Katina Constantina Calakos
Daniel Benjamin Ehrlich
Noa Golan
Okay.
Aneysis De Las Mercedes Gonzalez
Sharif Ismail Kronemer
Duy Phan
Yixiang Wang
For the degrees in International
and Development Economics,
Master of Arts:
Soha Fatima Ahmed
Svankita Rajeev Arora
Xiangyue Cao
Aditi Chaudhary
Ruoyu Chen
Xi Chen
Shang Rong Chia
Chloe Su En Chong
Harriet Jane Cross
Karan Daryanani Daryanani
Shubhangi Gokhroo
Elspeth Hughes Hughes
Shruti Jha
Lu Jin
Aishwarya Anna Kuruttukulam
Manasi Kutwal
Manojna Lanka
Marah Mohamed
Sanjana Rajeshwari Muthukrishnan
Meng Qiao
Aishwarya Rai
Vanessa Tan Siy Van
Lakshimi Swaminathan
Andre Tng
Simeng Wang
Aijing Wu
Doctor of Philosophy:
Makoto Mi
Dennis Shung
Stephan Siebel
Yu Zhang
For the degrees in Linguistics,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Sarah Babinski
Josh Phillips
Muye Zhang
For the degrees in Management,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Liu Canyao
Rahul Goravara
David Kwon
For the degrees in Mathematics,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Aaron Tomas Wright Calderon
Yakir Moshe Forman
Pratyush Sarkar
Elad Daniel Zelingher
Over here.
For the degrees in Medieval
Studies, Master of Art:
Emma Olson
Julian Zumbach
For the degrees in Microbiology,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Luying Liu
Donghyun Park
For the degrees in Molecular
Biophysics and Biochemistry,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Dahyana Arias Escayola
Josie Evelyn Bircher
Megan Rose Brady
Sachita Ganesa
For the degrees in Molecular,
Cellular, and Elemental Biology,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Emma Tung Corcoran
Michael Sean Mauro
Xavier Jr Portillo
Harini Sadeeshkumar
Renee Rhodes Wasko
Lauren Nicole Winkler
Xing Wu
For the degrees in Music, Doctor
of Philosophy:
Knar Abrahamyan
Clifton Boyd
Jacqueline Hilson Georgis
Alexandra Renée Krawetz
For the degrees in Near Eastern
Languages and Civilizations,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Kayla Dang
For the degrees in Nursing,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Shuyuan Huang
For the degrees in Pharmacology,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Michael Joseph Bond
Courtney McCaul Smith
For the degrees in Philosophy,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Brian David Earp
Lea Aurelia Schroeder
Rebecca Elizabeth Wolitz
For the degrees in Physics,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Kelly Marie Backes
Daniel Berkowitz
Emma Grace Castiglia
Paul Edward Fanto
Connor Hann
Emily Kuhn
Sangjae Lee
Michael Henry Oliver
Luis Elias Saldaña Santisteban
Hyungki Shim
Christopher Wang
Jovana Zagorac
For the degrees in Political
Science, Doctor of Philosophy:
Angele Delevoye
Sophie Jacobson
Constantine Msisiri Manda
Darren King Zhuan Nah
Over here.
Stephanie Almeida Nevin
Eli Gavin Rau
James Sundquist
For the degrees in Psychology,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Qi Lin
Paola Odriozola
Lauren Michelle Patrick
Estée Adrianna Rubien-Thomas
Colin Stanton
For the degrees in Public
Health, Doctor of Philosophy:
Hanna Y. Ehrlich
Kenneth Suranga Gunasekera
Boyang Li
Jiajun Luo
Alyssa Sholeh Parpia
Maile Thayer Phillips
Brian Thompson
Phoebe Tran
Elizabeth Bennett White
Yiliang Zhang
Master of Science:
Annan Deng
Chang Han
Zongjian He
Ziyi Kang
Lisa Kim
Jiaxuan Li
Xumin Li
Wenjing Meng
Lauren Pischel
Yiwen Shi
Peihan Song
Yihua Su
Meng Sun
Chichun Tan
Ningya Wang
Yuxuan Wang
Fangzhou Wei
Wenxin Xu
Nan Yang
Jiaxuan Zhao
Ziqiu Zheng
Yi Zhong
Mi Zhou
Zhaohan Zhu
For the degrees in Religious
Studies, Doctor of Philosophy:
Daniel Eastman An
Lynna Dhanani
Stephanie Machabee
Wendy Mallette
Cody Carolina Brown Musselman
Sarah Violet Zager
For the degreesn Renaissance
Studies, Doctor of Philosophy:
Thomas Santa Maria
For the degrees in Slavic
Languages and Literatures,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Ana Berdinskikh
Sean Blink
Anastasia Kostina
For the degrees in Sociology,
Doctor of Philosophy:
Patrice Danae Collins
Jacob Derechin
Kalisha Dessources Figures
Dana Hayward
Master's of Art:
Jessie Dong
For the degrees in Spanish and
Portuguese, Master's of Art:
Kate Tyra Olivier
For the degrees in Statistics,
Master's of art:
Justin Eli Cabot Miller
Laura Herren
Donald Kenney
Geoffrey Hersh Chenli Martin
Evaneet Kaur Sachar
For the degrees in Statistics
and Data Science, Doctor of
Philosophy:
Soham Jana
Ganlin Song
Sheng Xu
Master's of Science:
Aditya Biswas
Zhanlin Chen
Shiyao Gong
Xiaorou Liang
Jose Antonio Sidaoui Gali
Hidde Sebastiaan Verholt
Yiyang Wang
Tian Lu Xue
Fangming Xu
Zipei Zhu
Master's of Art:
Yiyun Chen
Candice Djorno
So, every year, for various
reasons, it happens that some
students are not able to sit
with their departments and come
forward for their diplomas in
the usual order.
So, now we award the final
degrees, which in some cases may
not appear in the program.
Doctor of Philosophy:
[ Reading of graduates' names ]
In Biomedical Engineering.
In immune
In Immunobiology.
[ Reading of graduates' names ]
In Physics.
In Public Health.
[ Reading of graduates' names ]
Master's of Arts in African
American Studies.
[ Reading of graduates' names ]
Master's of Arts in History.
International Development
Economics.
[ Reading of graduates' names ]
International and Developmental
Economics.
[ Reading of graduates' names ]
Master of Science, Public
Health.
[ Reading of graduates' names ]
In International and Development
Economics.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
Applied Physics.
DEAN COOLEY:  Thank you, Dean
Besirevic.
[ Applause ]
All right. As I call out each of
the degrees we've conferred
today, please stand up, if
that's the degree you got, and
remain standing while I ask
everyone here to congratulate
you.
Master of Arts.
Master of Science.
Master of Philosophy.
Doctor of Philosophy.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
Degree recipients, please remain
standing. Everyone else can have
a seat again. In the Graduate
School, we like to recognize
that the commitment of time,
effort, and attention required
to achieve an advanced degree is
only possible with the
participation and support of not
only our professors and
classmates, but also your
families and friends.
Therefore, invite all of our
degree recipients to turn and
acknowledge the roles played by
others in the achievements we
are celebrating together today.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
Okay, now you can be seated. New
alumni of the Graduate School,
you have been an integral part
of one of civilization's highest
inventions - the research
university where the mission is
the creation of new knowledge
and passing it along to next
generations.
As you have learned, finding new
knowledge, new truth about our
world is not a solitary
endeavor. You have lived within
an extensive academic network in
which you can follow your
curiosity, rigorously test your
ideas, benefit from critique,
and go forward in an unexpected
direction. You have learned that
a convincing argument backed by
evidence from primary sources or
well-controlled experiments will
stand up to careful scrutiny
and, importantly, pave the way
for the next person to take
another step.
Savor this. Rejoice in this.
It is a rare privilege to
possess this experience, and its
teachings can be applied
throughout your life.
It is now your responsibility to
spread that knowledge beyond the
brgs y, share what you have ture
learned and what you will learn.
Our world needs to know true
things, backed by hard-won
evidence, now more than ever.
Be the source of truth in the
midst of confusion and
mis-information. Take what you
have learned at Yale and make
the world a better place.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
I also ask you to reflect on the
people who helped you make it
through graduate school to find
your career path. As you
benefitted from being mentored,
consider being a mentor
yourself. Think about sharing
your knowledge and experience
with upcoming students through
the Graduate Student As
Alumni Association, or by
signing up to be part of
Cross-Campus, our portal for
bringing alumni and current
graduate students together for
networking and career support.
You may not realize how much
your experiences can already be
of benefit to others.
So, as we conclude:
Please remain in your seats
until the platform party
recesses from the auditorium.
Then, please process out using
the side exits, over here and
over here. So on the sides. On
to College Street o Beinecke
Plaza. Please do not exit
through the rotunda because the
School of Public Health is
waiting to begin their ceremony.
To that end, please exit quickly
so that the next ceremony can
begin on  time.
Our ushers will assist you in
finding your way out.
Graduates, you and your friends
and families, together with the
faculty and staff who are with
us, are invited to a reception
immediately following the
conclusion of this ceremony in
the Caulkins Courtyard at the
I hope you can join us. On
behalf of all of Yale,
congratulations!
[ Cheers and Applause ]
♪